it's got nothing to do with containment
and you Cobb or anything like that it's
simply a matter of keeping living up to
the responsibilities that on both sides
we've we've undertaken for example ice
extending the beer no passport holder
offer to come to the UK and the way I
described is not contingent on a free
trade deal or anything like that we
wouldn't allow that to be to get in the
way of us doing our living up to our
responsibilities as a matter of
principle and I think both for moral
reasons and national standing that's
really important international standard
we're not turning our back on the people
of Hong Kong but I do think it's right
to work with our international partners
to give China the breathing space if you
like have a look at this and to see
actually whether it's the right move and
with our international partners about
what we do next
equally we recognize China's a large
power a rising economic power and is a
leading member of the international
community I think the thing which will
take that shine if you like off that
rise not just the economic impact of
Kovach 19 but also if it can't live up
to the deals that it makes it comes down
to an issue of trust some people say
that the corona virus pandemic has
intensified tension between China and
the US potentially even creating the
climate for a new cold war do you agree
with that I think though as you said
there were tensions before coronavirus I
think there are questions to be asked
about how coronavirus started how its
spread and what lessons we can learn
which I would like to see all members of
the international community come
together in that endeavor and we need an
independent review it needs to be
absolutely rigorous there can't be any
stones left unturned we need to get the
answers so we can stop something like
that happening again
and we don't see this at all in Cold War
mindset but we do think there are some
very searching questions to be asked
equally this is an important moment of
global cooperation we've had excellent
cooperation I got to tell you on
coronavirus with the Americans of course
is a very close ally but actually also
with the Chinese so whether it's
securing critical personal protective
equipment for the NHS or whether it was
getting British nationals out of Wuhan
problems at the outset I had a good
cooperation with my opposite number in
China so you will take the rough with
the smooth I think is what I'm telling
you and we're not going to give up our
key interests or our moral values or
on Hong Kong but we also see that there
are there areas and scope for
cooperation with China and will pursue
those as well would you be willing to
stick to that that that agenda if China
demanded that a cost for a trade deal
would be that you do step back on Hong
Kong that you do accept who are way into
our networks we wouldn't sacrifice our
commitments the ones I've made in the
House of Commons to the people of Hong
Kong for free trade deal with China your
father received refuge from the UK does
that personal experience make the the
need the desire to help the people of
Hong Kong more than just something
that's part of your professional job my
family on my father's side came here we
offered all the huge opportunities that
Britain can give anyone relation to
freedom and tolerance but also economic
opportunities I was talking to pretty
Patel on Home Secretary about this as
well she feels the same way her family
came over the time that Idi Amin was
expelling Indians from Uganda and there
others around the cabinet table and I do
think that Britain is at its very best
with that big-hearted generosity of
spirit that defines our role in the
world not just at home and we've kind of
seen the country coming together with
the Solidarity people feel towards NHS
workers carers the clap for carers that
we've been doing on Thursdays and
actually there's something about that
open-hearted generosity spirit in the
world and I do think in relation to Hong
Kong with everything that we're seeing
about what's going on with our historic
responsibilities yes that does strike a
personal resonance with me just like a
legacy of our superpower status of the
past that just doesn't exist anymore and
we aren't relevant anymore we're not
powerful enough to have a voice it feels
very relevant today I think Britain
still has an incredible role in the
world as a force for good and I think
across those range those range of issues
I think there is still not in a colonial
out way we don't know one seriously
thinks that we're going back to that era
but actually Britain is a force for good
in a way which matches our interest in
our values in the 21st century you talk
tough on China in terms of Hong Kong but
what about our closest ally the United
States do you condemn the police
violence that we've seen in that country
over the last few days
against peaceful protesters well look
anyone that saw the footage of the
treatment of George Floyd would have
been moved and distressed as I was and I
think seeing the protests and the
violence is very distressing I want to
see America come together I don't see it
ripping itself apart there's a federal
review underway and of course that's
absolutely right and you mentioned media
freedoms and journalistic freedoms of
course the u.s. is a fine tradition of
protecting all of those things and yes
we do expect that to continue even when
journalists are being beaten up and a
British journalist arrested if you
raised that with the u.s. well we will
certainly look very carefully at the
details of that case and yes whether
it's in relation to the UK or otherwise
that we will raise all of those issues
in the normal way number of Premier
League football players have spoken very
passionately about the need for racial
equality in the wake of the the George
Floyd killing what do you say to them
when the president of our closest ally
uses a photo opportunity outside a
church to have peaceful protesters
blasted out the way look I haven't seen
the scene that you'll talk about but
look well when we think even our closest
friends closest partners and countries
with which we've got a long history as
now of course will raise those difficult
issues I probably don't have the same
latitude that that celebrities do but I
do understand Turkey because I'm like
there was Hamilton or anyone from the
BME
community who looks at that and wonders
what the world coming to though I share
that sense of distress and of course we
want to see America come together we
don't want to see it go back to what we
saw in the 60s and some of those
tensions and we'll work with our our
closest ally to see what more we can do
with anything to support that process I
mean when you look at the United States
and you see a president that talks about
America first who withdraws from the
World Health Organization in the middle
of a pandemic who rips up the Iran
nuclear deal do you think it's perhaps
time for the UK to reassess their status
as our most special ally actually I
think what British people would expect
is that we of course natural friendships
now and lines around the world but also
stand up with a British national
interest we made clear that actually we
still see that the World Health
Organization has a role to play yes
you want answers about how the
coronavirus started but we don't want to
rip up the whu-oh at a time of a global
health pandemic so I think that is a
good example where we just take a
different view and we'll be honest about
it
what are you envisage Britain's role is
in the world especially as we come out
of this pandemic with so much changed
well if you look at the how we talked
about global Britain part of that of
course is as we leave the EU forging
strong relations and making sure we good
European neighbors with our European
partners global Britain is also about us
being a force for good in the world
Prime Minister is hosting the GAVI
summit tomorrow which is this summit to
get us up to seven point four billion
dollars worth of funding for vaccine
development we're confident that that's
going to be a success we need to bring
other countries together in that
endeavor and I think it's a good example
of the UK's role bringing countries
together as a force for good in the
world and you know we're living and
breathing it right now and I think
there's a great opportunity for us in
the future to expand on that thank you
very much